pascal mousset président du groupe
national des indépendants en ile de
france indique a donc des hôteliers et
restaurateurs également avec notre
éditorialiste alexis poule à un bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
alors emmanuel macron at il changé sa
méthode ça fait de mauvaises langues
dont vous ne faites pas partie
évidemment les petits poulains disent
que le président a enfin annoncé un cap
alors c'est vrai qu'on a eu droit à
trois dates 1 hier soir c'était assez
précis vous trouvez vous pose la même
question qui hier qu'il a répondu aux
attentes des français alexis poulain
tout de même
écoutez il a donné trois dates on
appelle ça un cap
alors que plus de questions se posent
sur le contrôle des malades des cas
contact jusqu'à obliger à rester chez
soi à toujours plus d'amande la question
des vaccins
finalement non obligatoire avec un
vaccin deux premières injections de
deuxième génération
un nouveau groupe de parole de citoyens
pour faire croire qu'il ya de la
transparence
quel cap encore une fois c'est assez
brouillon alors il y avait un peu plus
de jean castex chez emmanuel macron hier
il est rentré dans les détails c'est
vrai il a rappelé les gestes que
barrières qu'il fallait aussi si on
recevait des amis à la maison pour les
fêtes
gardez le masque à la maison super la
bamboche donc oui peut-être que c'est un
cap on peut appeler ça un cap moi
j'appelle ça du détail j'appelle ça
toujours cette absurdistan qui se
prolonge dans les dates
alors oui ça patauge parce que le
déconfinement été raté hélas il ne veut
pas rater le deuxième déconfinement
sachant que déjà l'exécutif européen est
en train de préparer l'opinion à une
potentielle troisième vague si toutefois
ça allait trop vite donc il faut que les
français restent chez eux à tout prix
est malade ou pas d'ailleurs et qu'ils
sortent pour consommer quand même pour
les commerces qui auront la chance de
pouvoir ouvrir
moi je pense au commerce qui n'ouvriront
pas avant le 20 janvier les bars des
restaurants aux boîtes de nuit qui ont
fermé boutique depuis le mois de mars et
qui n'ont pas rouvert ses secteurs qui
sont sinistrées et pour longtemps et
l'aide qu'ils ne suffira pas donc oui
encore une gestion sanitaire
qui reste pour moi de l'improvisation
alors trois dates c'est pas un cap ces
trois dates alors pas de réouverture
effectivement possible avant le 20
janvier vous l'avait dit pour les
restaurateurs
vous vous y attendiez où c'est un
nouveau coup dur pour les professionnels
du secteur passe qu'annoncé c'est une
grande tristesse c'est une angoisse
évidemment on avait ça avait fuité un
petit peu ces annonces on savait très
bien que l'ouverture pour les fêtes
était compromise on espérait quand même
que les stations de montagne allait être
un petit peu épargné aujourd'hui il ya
une grande angoisse de la profession
deux mois ça fera 2 talent de plus de
six mois de fermeture administrative
pour les restaurants on pense aussi aux
hôteliers aux traiteurs qui n'ont pas de
fermeture administrative mais qui ont
les mêmes conséquences économiques que
les restaurants les hôtels ont même des
baisses d'activité encore plus
importante parce que les gens ne se
déplacent pas et donc aujourd'hui on ne
mesure pas encore l'étendue de cette
crise il ya eu des annonces
d'accompagnement économique qui demande
à être précisés qui semblerait aller
dans une bonne direction mais qui
n'efface rompt jamais les six mois de
fermeture
donc aujourd'hui nous on a besoin de
travailler on a envie de travailler
et puis on a emmené dans l'inconnu on
est dans un tunnel
on est dans dans l'obscurité et on voit
pas la lumière et le 20 janvier ça a été
également annoncée avec des réserves
si vous avez bien entendu le président a
dit sous réserve que les conditions
sanitaires soient requises ainsi poquet
du relâchement pendant les fêtes et
qu'on ait une troisième vague ça veut
dire que cette date ne serait pas tenue
pour nous c'est insupportable alors pas
mal de réactions politiques en tout cas
à l'issue de cette allocution je propose
d'écouter celles du numéro deux de la
france insoumise le député du nord
adrien satanas intervention bavarde du
chef du nouveau régime autoritaire qui
en appelle à la bienveillance à la
démocratie et l'humanisme comme hier
soir place de la république ont résumé
les commerces n'auraient jamais dû
fermer et pour le reste rendez vous le
15 décembre
oui notre réaction avant nous fait
réagir alexis poulain sel
cette fois de nicolas dupont aignan
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement ne
prenne aucune des mesures de bon sens
que je propose depuis des mois et qui
permettrait d'éviter une troisième vague
tests systématiques aux frontières
protection renforcée en ehpad
augmentation du nombre de lits en
réanimation
alors c'est vrai qu'on tire beaucoup à
boulet rouge sur la gestion du
gouvernement alexis est poulain mais
c'est vrai qu'à d'autres voix
dissonantes qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu
faire autrement et qu'est ce qu'on
aurait pu faire mieux surtout sur un
virus aussi imprévisible et bien donner
les moyens à l'hôpital tout simplement
renforcer les livres faire une formation
rapide de réanimation pour les
personnels déjà là on a demandé beaucoup
aux soignants sans leur donner beaucoup
d'aidants réalité puisque pendant dans
l'antre de confinement les lions
continuer de fermer vous avez des
services d'urgences à en plein paris qui
ont fermé le l'agenda est clair
l'hôpital tient donc continuons de lui
demander l'impossible inutile de lui
donner des moyens c'est ça la
philosophie du gouvernement c'est faire
que tous tiennent jusqu'à ce que ça
craque et si jamais ça craque et bien
les groupes privés arriveront dans la
danse et puis on pourra vent de la santé
c'est ce que disait urgentiste patrick
peloux récemment et c'est partout pareil
l'agenda aujourd'hui de ce gouvernement
c'est de faire passer des mesures qui
serait impensable
le travail le dimanche qui est de la
présenter comme une chance pour les
commerces qui vont pouvoir ouvrir le
dimanche jusqu'à 21h quelle chance sans
aucun cadre législatif simplement pour
dire vous rattraperez votre chiffre
d'affaires je crois que beaucoup de
syndicats vont poser des questions dans
le cadre du droit du travail
et puis pareil sur le reste de
l'économie
bruno le maire qui parle de il n'y aura
pas de nouvel impôt non par contre il y
aura plein de nouvelles amendes à ça on
a compris que la mangue pour non port du
masque la menthe pour sortir de chez soi
on va se faire finalement allumé pour
tout et n'importe quoi dans ce pays ce
sera ça le nouvel impôt l'amande
illégitime d'une certaine façon est en
revanche la loi sur les retraites qui
est prête à être de nouveau discutée
pour vraiment la faire passer en faisant
de toute façon cette dette qu'on
accumule qui est une éponge abl
impayable on parle de 20 ans 30 ans 25
ans eh bien on l'appellera par le
travail des français et le travail qui
va s'allonger dans des conditions de
plus en plus difficile puisque la
croissance
ne nous leurrons pas ne va pas revenir à
son niveau d'avant crise en 2021 par un
coup de baguette magique
donc cette crise sanitaire n'est pas
gérée de manière salutaire elle est
gérée de manière autoritaire et elle a
créé une crise économique
et cette crise économique va être le
coeur du problème en 2021 puisque le
vaccin qui est l'espoir est censé
arriver et résoudre le problème mais le
problème économique il n'est pas réglée
et vous en parler on nous en parlons ce
soir les nombreux commerces qui ont
fermé le manque à gagner ne va pas être
trouvées je ne sais pas combien de tpe
et pme vont mettre la clé sous la porte
à cause de cette politique autoritaire
on a l'impression et c'est ce qu'on
entendait hier quand emmanuel macron
parler qu'il décide au bon gré à son bon
vouloir finalement en disant j'ai décidé
que le vaccin ne serait pas obligatoire
c'est lui qui décide ah d'accord
donc si demain il décide que le vaccin
sera obligatoire ce sera lui qui
décidera pareil pour le 20 janvier c'est
lui qui décide comment ça se passe
comment peut-on tolérer que sept grands
pays cette grande démocratie qu'est la
france soit gérée comme ça par quelqu'un
enfermé dans un château en plein coeur
de paris c'est chose hier on reparlera
effectivement d'une vexant d'or dans
quelques instants mais tout d'abord
parce qu'elle nous c'est sur ce que
vient de dire alexis poule à sur les
thèmes les tpe il ya quand même eu des
annonces 20% jusqu'à 20% du chiffre
d'affaires ou alors une indemnité de
10000 euros d'indemnisation pour les
petites entreprises ça peut être
intéressant ce n'est pas suffisant
pascal mousset ça va quand même
permettre de sauver entre guillemets des
des vies dans les entreprises il faut
savoir ces aides correspondant un mode
survie aujourd'hui il fallait les
restaurateurs et une contrepartie à ce
qu'on leur demande de d'assumer c'est à
dire encore deux mois de fermeture se
priver des fêtes où tous les petits
commerces et tous les français vont
pouvoir se retrouver autour de la table
mais pas dans nos états
glissement donc il fallait nous donner
quelque chose on nous a donné quelque
chose qui est bien loin de ce qu'on
demandait qui est bien loin de couvrir
les pertes qu'on aura assumé sur ces six
mois de fermeture et cette année où il a
fallu appliquer des distanciation social
réduire nos jauge et dégrader
considérablement nos affaires on perd
clairement de l'argent depuis le 14 mars
aujourd'hui on a eu des prêts garantis
par l'état on sortira pour les meilleurs
d'entre nous ou les plus chanceux je
sais pas qui est ce qu'il faut comment
il faut le qualifier avec beaucoup de
dettes et autres appâts dix ans pour les
banques pour rembourser ses dettes
et puis malheureusement pour 30% d'entre
nous on va devoir mettre la clé sous la
porte
donc pour en 2021 en fait c'est pge
c'est cette c'est une survie
artificielle on les consomme tous les
jours depuis le 14 mars
c'est pas inépuisables canton sera
arrivé au bout de ce pécule
on sera obligé de déposer les clés de
nos établissements et on ne pourra plus
battre parce qu'on aura plus de
ressources et ceux qui pourront
continuer à se battre ça sera pour dix
années de dur labeur pour payer cette
dette
donc ça va se traduire aussi par une
casse sociale qu'on mesure pas encore
parce que notre métier fait partie des
des métiers qui permettent le lien
social qui permettent la promotion
interne qui permettent de monter
l'échelle sociale
on est souvent cité en exemple avec le
bâtiment comme une fin facteurs nos
métiers d'intégration sociale et non on
met beaucoup en garde les pouvoirs
publics sur la disparition des savoir
faire et sur le fait que ces jeunes qui
ne pourront plus accéder à nos métiers
parce qu'on aura plus de travail pour
eux on se trouve un petit peu en
déshérence et ça nous fait un petit peu
peur et ça nous fait aussi mal au coeur
parce qu'on est des métiers où l'humain
dominant fin on est on est on aime les
gens quand on fait ce métier on aime les
clients on aime nos collaborateurs c'est
une grande famille
et ça nous plonge dans une détresse
parce qu'on manquait beaucoup de
personnel encore jusqu'en début 2020 et
tout d'un coup on a beaucoup trop des
deux collaborateurs
on doit s'en séparer pour beaucoup
d'entre nous et on se dit tout ça pour
ça andré alexis poule à en parler il ya
quelques instants l'autre temps fort
l'un des temps forts de cette allocution
c'est le dossier du vaccin la stratégie
évidemment de tous les pays évidemment
la france également pour sortir du
tunnel
un vaccin qui ne sera pas obligatoire en
france on écoute emmanuel macron la
vaccination doit se faire de manière
claire transparente en partageant à
chaque étape
toutes les informations ce que nous
savons comme ceux que nous ne savons pas
et je veux aussi être clair je ne
rendrai pas la vaccination obligatoire
alors là alexis poulain on peut se poser
des questions parce que c'est vrai qu'on
sait les français assez sceptique
vis-à-vis vexin peut-être donc ce qui
expliquerait cette réponse d'emmanuel
macro et enfin nous a quand même confiné
d'autorité plusieurs fois c'était le cas
dans d'autres pays mais tout de même
et là on ne rend pas le vaccin
obligatoire est ce que tout cela a un
sens selon vous oui c'est un sens assez
de créer la confusion toujours c'est de
continuer avec la peur et puis c'est
aussi de faire douter sur ce vaccin de
se réserver une porte de sortie si
jamais le s'avéraient inefficaces parce
qu'on ne sait pas grand chose sur ce
vaccin c'est ce que dit madame à caen
que la transparence soit faite je suis
d'accord aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on sait
sur les candidats vaccins puisqu'il n'y
en a pas un qui est sorti du chapeau
encore ce sont des communiqués de presse
fait par les laboratoires pour les
marchés financiers et ça marche le
patron par exemple d'un grand
laboratoire a pu vendre ses actions le
jour de l'annoncé et empoché plus de 5,6
millions de dollars dans le cadre d'un
plan d'action qui était tout à fait
légal donc aujourd'hui ce sont des
annonces d'abord financière et puis il
ya la question du poids des lobbys dans
cette course à la vaccination
on a des précédents sur la transparence
leur md et vire acheté à plus d'un
milliard par la commission européenne
or il se trouve que le rêve des virées
maintenant des conseillers par l'om est
ce parce qu'ils seraient
dangereux il y aurait des effets
secondaires assez dangereux pour les
malades du corps vide or qu'est-ce qui
se passe et bien la commissaire
européenne à la santé a eu un rendez
vous par mois depuis le mois de juillet
avec gilead rendez vous téléphonique
eh bien j'aimerais qu'on n'essaie
rendez-vous transparent qu'est que c'est
il discutait qu'est ce qui a été dit
dans ces rendez vous et puis si on veut
de la transparence
quel est l'état des contrats entre les
autorités européennes et les
laboratoires
est ce que les citoyens peuvent avoir
accès à ces contrats est ce qu'on peut
lire ces contrats donc oui je suis
d'accord pour la transparence mais
certainement pas avec un comité de
citoyens qui veillera à la transparence
on a le précédent du comité citoyen sur
le climat tout ça est de la cosmétique
de la communication politique la vraie
transparence c'est que les citoyens
aient accès aux contrats qu'ils aient
accès aussi aux études médicales qui
seront publiés par les laboratoires
aujourd'hui elles n'ont été publiés
nulle part ces études médicales ce sont
uniquement des communiqués de presse
donc à un moment je veux bien qu'on dise
qu en janvier tout le monde se fait
vacciner avant de se faire vacciner
sachant de quoi il est question dans le
petit tube et puis aussi comment
vacciner le vaccin moderna ces vaccins
arn moderne qui mais nécessite d'être
stockés à moins de 80 degrés alors un
médecin de ville pourra pas vous
vacciner donc comment ça va se passer on
aura des vaccinodromes avec des grand
frigo et puis il faudra passer à la
chaîne
sachant les risques de contamination du
coup si jamais il ya des incas contact
au milieu des gens qui font la queue
pour se faire vacciner
donc encore une fois énormément de
questions et le fait que c'est le
monarque qui décide en disant j'ai
décidé que le vaccin serait pas
obligatoire mais douce et un président
politique qui décide s'il décide de la
transparence
alors elle doit être démocratique elle
devrait être sous le sceau du parlement
même si malheureusement le parlement est
plutôt du côté de la censure est
d'enfermer les gens chez eux leur mettre
des amendes mais au moins qu'on ait un
contrôle démocratique et transparent
réellement pascaline c'est la question
s'adresse évidemment ni un médecin ni un
expert mais vous tout simplement tant
que citoyen vous voyez le bout du tunnel
avec ce vaccin vous êtes plutôt confiant
une très sceptiques comme beaucoup de
français c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour le
dire aujourd'hui on n'a pas
c'est l'information disons
qu'aujourd'hui tout ce qui peut
présenter un espoir dans la position de
chef d'entreprise où on se trouve dans
dans le brouillard tout ce qui peut
représenter un espoir un peu de lumière
on a envie d'y croire et je dirais que
moi à titre personnel je serais enclin à
faire confiance à un vaccin si on
pouvait produire un vaccin français mais
après aujourd'hui nous on s'accroche à
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer la détresse
dans laquelle nous sommes avec nos
collaborateurs et tout ce qui peut
représenter un espoir
on a envie d'y croire alors aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est un débat
scientifique qui nous échappe
complètement
on aurait envie de faire confiance après
il faut comme comme l'a dit mon voile à
l'intervenant qui qui qui qui est avec
nous il faut nous donner la transparence
il faut qu'on ait tous les éléments en
main aujourd'hui nous propose un
catalogue de vaccins et il faudrait nous
indiquer d'une façon transparente les
avantages et les inconvénients pour qu
on puisse aller dans cette direction
mais c'est vrai que vous riez des
vaccins obligatoires
moi je serais tenté de dire aujourd'hui
si on est une grande nation scientifique
et si on à l'institut pasteur
on devrait être capable de pouvoir
assurer la sécurité de la vaccination
est donc la rendre obligatoire pour
permettre de sortir de cette crise au
plus vite parce que la crise économique
qui nous attend je crains qu'elle soit
encore plus importante que la crise
sanitaire que vous ne nous venons de
vivre
c'est ça qui nous fait peur nous chefs
d'entreprise c'est qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans cette année 2021 après le
voyage nous on a besoin d'espoir de
visibilité
le vaccin c'est cette une c'est une stan
espoirs ce qui nous désole c'est de voir
qu'en asie l'activité a repris que dans
beaucoup de pays asiatiques
tout ça est derrière eux et que nous on
a l'impression que c'est encore devant
nous alors que la crise nous a surpris
simplement un mois après où deux mois
donc c'est ça qui nous effraie un peu le
retard etc
mick comprend par rapport aux pays
d'asie par exemple merci en tout cas
tous les deux avec seal poulain pascal
mons et d'avoir été avec nous